Okay. So we're talking about alkenes and
in particular today we're going to be
talking,
continuing to talk about polymerization
in the context of things that nature
makes, what are called, which
are called ice of paranoids.
And then we'll talk about the properties
of polymers and then go onto a settled
liens.
Uh,
we're talking about electronic files being
the things that attack a double bonds
in particular ones where
the electro file is carbon,
like the sigma star of something
with a leaving group on it or the,
with an electronegative negative
group on it, or a cad I ion.
And we're talking about the
synthesis of Turpines and steroids.
So there's a key,
a molecule called ISO Penn Tino Pyro,
phosphate, pyro. Phosphate is this thing
with two fos versus linked by an oxygen,
right? And it turns out you can do
an alcoholic rearrangement. I mean,
when I say you, I mean you, I mean
the enzymes in you do it. Okay?
So you can get from Iso Penn,
Tino pyro phosphate, uh, to, uh,
to die methyl allium pyro phosphates,
which he knows involves a shift
of a hydrogen, uh, Al illegally.
Okay? Now, the reason you do
that is to make it better for sn.
Two reactions.
If you look at the relative rate for
displacement of chloride by Ayah done an
acetone,
if you call it one for purple chloride,
if you make allium chloride, so you
put a double bond to make that bond,
the carbon chlorine bond Alec,
it goes up by almost a
hundred fold a factor of 90.
And if it's a benzene ring instead
of just a regular old double bond,
it goes up another factor
of two and a half. Okay,
so apparently this an
adjacent unsaturation,
that new double bond is
especially good at at uh,
in state,
in stabilizing after the transition state.
So at the time when chloride is
leaving and iodide is coming in,
the double bond is able to
interact with that orbital.
That's bonding simultaneously,
that pentavalent carbon,
a transition state.
So both sn two as well as sn one where
you draw a resonance structure for that
kind of interaction for the cat
eye. And it's good to have it, Alec.
So notice that this shift is Lle shift
from ISO Penn Tino pyro phosphate to die
methyl alcohol.
Pyrophosphate resulted in getting the
leaving group to be alcoholic so that
it'll be easier to displace.
Now why do you do that? Okay,
so you can take as a nucleophile then if
you have this really good leaving group,
you can take as a nucleophile the
ice of Pantene. Oh pyrophosphate.
So it's a carbon that's serving
as the nuclear file, right?
So you make a new bond,
get a cad ion, right?
But the cat eye and can be lost by
losing a proton next door to make a new
double bond.
What you'll notice is a new aloe lake
functionality with the leaving group,
right? So you've put two of these things
together and you have the same kind of
functionality you had at the beginning.
Okay?
And that thing is called Gera Neal
pyro phosphate because it's related to
Geraniums
as we'll see.
Notice that the starting material has
five carbons. Now having put two together,
you have 10.
Okay?
So if you take Jared annealed
pyro phosphate and uh,
I samurais the double bond,
then it's in a position for the other
double bond in the same molecule to be the
nucleophile,
right?
So you can do that and get
that cat eye on right now.
What could that cat eye and do?
Well,
of course it could do the same thing
it did before and lose a proton. Right?
And that gives Lyman nene and I made it
a sort of yellow green, you know why?
Cause it made a little bit like lemons
or limes that lemon grass oil is Lyman.
Ian in Asian cooking has
that. Okay. If you bend it up,
then you can see another possibility.
What other possibility do you see?
If I draw the confirmation more
like that? I don't, I got an idea,
right?
The double that double bond could add
to the vacant orbital along the carbon
like that, uh, Markovnikov
addition. It's not what, what,
why is it not so good on her eye
forms a four membered rings. There's
going to be some rings strain there,
but it does happen, right?
And if you lose the Proton,
now you'd get a compound
called Beta pinene.
Guess what kind of trees that comes from?
Okay?
Okay. Now you could also do
an anti Markovnikov addition,
which doesn't form quite as strained
to ring, right? If you do that.
And then they had water and lose a
proton to the carbon cat eye and you get,
uh, uh, after oxidation
camphor, which of course,
now all of these things have in common
that they have very characteristic odors.
Lemon, the Pinene
Turpentine Camphor, right?
So these things are called
turpines essential oils.
Terpene is from Turpentine, right?
That's where pioneer pioneer's,
the major constituent of
Turpentine. Essential oils.
Does it mean you need them?
What it means is they have an essence.
They have an odor.
So these see tens are volatile
and your nose responds to them.
So these are essential oils, uh, okay.
And notice their see tens
terpenes or see tens.
But now you can do more of the same.
If you start with your journey,
you'll pyrophosphate that you had before,
you could add another ISO Pentane oh,
pyrophosphate and yet a thing that's
called farnesyl. Pyrophosphate. Right?
And things that come from that,
like the compounds that came in from
the sea 10 we're called turpines.
These are called sesquiterpenes.
Do you know what [inaudible] means?
You know what assessed with centennial is
Sasquatch? Anybody? It
means one and a half, right?
So it's one and a half turpines 15
it's actually three of the ice of Penn.
Dino pirate phosphates. But the
name terpene came first. Okay?
So for example,
carry awfully in which is in clove and
hemp and rosemary is a Sasquatch terpene.
Okay?
Now two of those things can come together
and now this reaction is different
because it's not the
double bond attacking.
It's two of these Alec positions
coupling with one another.
It's a different kind of reaction.
We're not going to talk about it,
but at couples to give this,
which is squalene or shark liver oil.
Okay? And you'll see the new bond in the
middle. It's symmetric about the middle.
Now you can do interesting
things with squalene.
What kind of terpene in would you
call it? Incidentally? Squash lead.
If you take two fifteens you get 30 right?
So what are you going to call it?
Is it a mano terpy Sas
Suite, terpene. Diterpene,
right. It's a trite terpene to
one and a half since three, right?
So this is a trite derpy, but there are
a lot more important try turpines well,
more important. They come from this.
So this one is a starting point. Okay,
so they're squealing and I'm going
to twist it around into a special con
formation like that. Now, what
allows me to do that enzymes, right,
that hold these things in particular
shapes and now I'm going to react with
oxygen and do an EFP oxidation. Of
course, it's not just, Oh, it's a,
it's something like the reagents we talked
about, except it's done biologically,
but we're not interested in the
particulars of the biological reagents,
but it makes an EFP oxide notice
that it's able to do it selectively.
It gets only that double
bond among all those. Right?
And now you've protonate that.
And what will it do?
Can you see a way this can become more
stable? What's, what's makes it unstable?
Yeah, the ring strains. So how do you
get rid of the rings strain? Yeah.
Which way are you going to
break it?
Yeah. You're either going to break this
bond or this bond or this bond. One,
two, three, two. Why Two?
Stability. Pardon me?
Why better stability?
No,
so what's happened?
These electrons that are shared between
Oh and carbon are going to come onto the
oxygen bottle, right? It's
a tertiary carbocat ion.
If you break it your way. Okay,
so we'll do it that way. Okay.
Now what's that going to do?
Anybody got an idea?
Okay.
Now what have we been looking at?
Attacking double bonds.
We're looking at carbon cat ions
attacking double bonds. Any possibilities?
You see?
Okay.
Now you're going to form a bond between
this cat eye and then either the bottom
one or the top one.
Which one do you want to go
to? Bottom or top. If you have
a cat I and they had into an lt
white long.
Who?
Who would say that's a good idea?
Mark on the cough would say it's
a good idea. You're right. Okay,
so we do look at my coffee in the
competition. Okay, what happens next?
No? Well you got an idea.
Do the same thing again.
Do another mark in the competition.
Okay.
What's next?
Wrong
this time it's an anti
Markovnikov addition because
of the way the molecule is
held there. Okay. Okay. But now
you're set up to do another one,
a Markovnikov coffin.
Okay.
And now you might think you'd use that
last double bond and make another ring
since you're on a roll
here. Right. But you don't.
And the reason is the way the molecule
is held so that that one's not in
position to do the trick,
but something else happens
that's noticed. That's nice and
stable. It's a tertiary cad ion,
but there's another tertiary cat eye and
available. Do you see how to get to it?
Sebastian? You got an idea? Yeah.
How can I get from this cat iron to a
different tertiary cat eye and one that
we'd be just the same.
Sable Hydra chip.
Okay.
So that's tertiary,
but we can do a hydride shift
and get another tertiary one.
Okay.
And the ideas for the next one?
Yeah. Lauren, you got an idea?
We have a nice stable tertiary cat on it.
We could go back there probably any,
any other possibilities?
We're getting a tertiary one.
Oh, the one on the left. You could
do another hydride shift. Okay,
so that's tertiary to what's
next. Arvin, do you got an idea?
You might as well just do like the math.
You can be a mess out here.
They're not side shift.
Yeah. Okay, good. Next.
Antonio
other notified shift.
Oh boy. We're really
going into town now. What?
Hydride shift.
Obviously right,
wrong.
This time the proton just gets lost.
So it goes that way. The Arrow, right?
It makes a double bond
and the proton goes away.
Now that stuff is La Nostra Raul,
and that's the sort of the source of
cholesterol and all the steroid hormones.
You remember these few things we
showed last time that Barton was,
look looking at all these steroids.
They have a six membered, six members,
six membered ring than a five membered
ring and something substituted at the top.
They all come from here.
So these are triterpenes.
Now that's a cute story,
but one wonders whether it's true.
Okay?
And we'll show how,
you know it's true that once we get
to Nmr spectroscopy a week after next
probably. Okay. But you'll have
to hold your breath until that.
So there's these ice preens then you
can think about rearranging those double
bonds.
Notice that ISO Penn Tino pyrophosphate
has this c five unit in. But if you're,
if you do that,
you could make two new bonds.
I'm not talking about cad and anti
and mechanisms, just schematic here.
So if you have two ice Sabrina's,
you could link it together like that.
And that's Geranium oil
rose oil, right? Or,
or you can have two ice supreme
and put them together like that.
And that's menthol.
Or You could have four of them
and put them together like that.
And that's retinal.
The aldehyde over on the right.
So that's the thing that's involved in
vision or that absorbs light in your eyes.
So it's a a tetramer.
Okay.
Or you can take 30,000 die supreme
means and link them together like that.
And that's latex.
The Latin word latex just met a liquid,
but now it's always applied
to this particular liquid,
the SAP that runs out of
these trees that have a,
a Brazilian sis and there's a real
romantic story about this and how, uh,
you know,
explorers stole seeds from Brazil,
which was trying to keep them and took
them to England and grew them in queue
and then sent them to southeast Asia to
make rubber plantations like this and
that the rubber plantations
in Brazil failed because they,
that once you put the trees all close
together so that you could harvest them
efficiently rather than sending slaves
out into the Amazon to find a tree here
in a tree there.
Then it turned out they got a disease
that killed all the ones down in South
America. Henry Ford had a real
disaster with that. But anyhow,
you get that SAP and we showed you the
PSAP last time and we made a rubber ball
with it like this.
Okay.
Now that stuff was called by the Indians
could choke and in fact that's the name
and for,
for a rubber in French.
So people tried to find a use
for it in the west, know the,
the natives made balls, they
made a galoshes, you know,
you put your foot down in latex and let
it dry and then you've got a rubber boot.
Uh, so they, there were lots of things,
but it was difficult to work with.
Thomas Hancock and England developed a
thing called a masticator to try to chew
it up to make it so you could
make different things with it.
And Charles McIntosh and
Scotland in 1823 sandwich the,
the rubber between cloth layers
to make waterproof, you know,
that's what you call a waterproof
jacket and Britain as a Macintosh.
The we,
the reason you had to Sacha sandwich it
was because the stuff is really sticky.
I had a piece I was going to bring
that I made last time and I forgot to,
but it's really sticky stuff.
So that's not so good. Right.
It gets really gooey in the heat
and it's brittle in the cold.
So there's a fairly narrow temperature
range where it's useful. Okay.
Until Charles Goodyear in
1839 figured out the product,
the process of vulcanization,
which made this stuff,
uh,
useful.
So this is his own description from his
autobiography in 1855 of the discovery
of Balkanization,
he actually,
he was really nuts about rubber.
Incidentally,
the word rubber was coined by,
uh, by priestly, the guy invented,
discovered oxygen,
right. And you know why?
Because you use it for an eraser
to rub out pencil marks. So rubber.
Okay. Uh, but anyhow, uh,
good year really loved
rubber in this book.
He printed several copies on paper,
but other copies he printed on rubber,
which have now all stuck together
and you can't open any of the pages.
But anyhow, in describing his
discovery, he said he, that is himself.
Speaking of the third person here,
he was surprised to find that the specimen
being carelessly brought into contact
with a hot stove charged like leather.
So he was trying to figure some
way to make it not be sticky.
So he thought you could put a powder
on it to keep it from being sticky.
And the powder he'd try
was trying was sulfur,
but he was in Woburn mass when he was
doing this and he dropped it on a hot
stove and it charred, whereas
usually it melted, right? So he,
this surprised him.
So he got his friends and relations.
It says he endeavored to
call the attention of his
brother as well as some other
individuals who were present and who
were acquainted with the manufacturer of
gum elastic to this effect as remarkable.
And unlike any before known since gum
elastic always melted when exposed to a
high degree of heat,
the occurrence did not at the time
seemed to them to be worthy of notice.
It was considered as one of the frequent
appeals that he was in the habit of
making in behalf of some new experiment.
So they,
they're tired of all his
inventions. Right. But, uh,
he showed it to Benjamin Solomon
at Yale and Solomon wrote,
having seen experiments made and also
performed them myself with the India
rubber prepared by Mr. Charles Goodyear.
I can state that it does not melt,
but rather chars by heat.
And that does not stiffen by cold.
But retains its flexibility with cold
even when laid between cakes of ice.
So this is what a good year, who didn't
have much money needed in terms of a,
a serious endorsement to go out
and try to get some capital to,
to commercialize this.
So he got a patent and this is the
beginnings of the patent and he says he
claims combining said gum with
sulfur and with white LED's.
So it was the form of triple compound.
The lead's not used anymore in combined
in combination with the foregoing the
process of exposing the India rubber
fabric to the action of a high degree of
heat.
He had made a whole bunch of raincoats,
sort of Macintosh style and
it put them in the, in the uh,
closet during the summer to bring
out when they got rainy again.
And when he went to get them,
they were just all one big gooey mass.
So this was really a appealing to him to
patent this though he could make fabric
from it.
This is 1844 seven years later was the
crystal palace exhibition in London,
that try of industry in the
West in the Victorian period.
So there was this,
these industrial displays of the best
products from all over the world.
And here only seven
years after the patent,
we find Goodyear's vulcanized court
where he's pushing the beauties of rubber
and you see there's a desk and that desk
is made of rubber and it still exists.
It's in a museum up in Waterbury.
He made everything out of rubber.
You can't believe all the things he
made out or he proposed making bills for
currency out of rubber so that you
could wash them without destroying them.
A lot of these things didn't catch on
Sony. I latex was a po. Is this polymer?
What do you do when you
heat it with sulfur? Well,
you have several chains next to one
another and no one knows exactly how it
works,
but somehow it joins adjacent chains
with sulfur to make cross links between
these polymer chain.
So probably there are radical
addition reactions to double bonds,
radical Lilach substitutions.
So you get maybe this Al [inaudible],
which attacks the sulfur and then
that adds to the other double bond,
some something like this. But anyhow,
it makes cross links in the chains.
So how does that affect the
physical properties of the polymers?
Remember the problem is that it gets
gooey when it's hot and brittle when it's
cold,
which is not what you want in a coat.
So we're going to study this a little
bit and we're going to follow a really,
uh,
important scientists who published this
in 18 three description of a property of
Qucik or Indian rubber with
some reflections on the
cause of Alaska. [inaudible]
of this substance.
So this was done by John Gfe who lived
1757 to 1825 of was a very interesting
person. He, he was, uh, he
tutored John Dalton for example.
He lived up in the Lake
district in England and
Wordsworth wrote of him in this
a poem excursion.
No flower blooms throughout the
lofty range of these rough hills,
nor in the woods that
could from him conceal its
birthplace non who's figure did
not live upon his touch touch.
Because when guff was three years old,
he had rheumatic fever and
went blind. Right? So he was,
he was a great scientist though, blind.
So everything he had to do by, uh,
by touch or description of someone else.
So all of these studies of rubber,
he did blind. Okay. So
here's the beginning of this.
He lived in Middle Shaw
House near Kendall in 18,
two he said to substance called Qucik
or Indian rubber possesses a singular
property, which I believe has never
been taken notice of in printed,
at least by any English writer.
Okay. So here it goes on and he says,
uh, I made a piece of Coochie, a little
heavier than an equal bulk of water,
the temperature of which was 45 degrees.
The vessel containing the resident
water was then placed on the fire.
And when the contents of it
were heated to 130 degrees,
the COO chook floated on the surface.
What does that say about the density of
cooked Chook and the influence of heat
on it
and pardon?
It got well, it got less dense, right?
Cause you know water gets less
dense when you heat it up.
So when it was cold at sank,
when it was hot, it floated.
So it must expand when you heat
it more than water does. Okay,
so he didn't. Rubber makes it
expand more than water. Okay,
that's the first that,
that's not a great surprise.
That's not the important thing. Experiment
one is the important thing here.
He says, hold one end of
the slip of, of the rubber,
thus prepared between the thumb
and forefinger of each hand.
Bring the middle of the piece into
slight contact with the edges of the lips
because he has to do it by touch,
right?
Taking care to keep it
straight all the time,
but not to stretch it much
beyond its natural length.
After taking these preparatory steps,
extend the slip suddenly and you
will immediately perceived something.
So we're going to repeat his thing,
but I need a balloon there.
Okay? So everybody takes their balloon
and we'll do what gfes says to do here.
Okay?
So hold it between your thumb and finger
and put it against your upper lip and
stretch it a little bit. Okay? And
now having stretched a little bit,
stretch it as hard as you can
while it's against your lip.
You notice that anything
who's a sensitive as John Gfe here,
what happened?
And what's really interesting
is you stretch it pretty
far and not much happens,
but the last inch makes a difference.
You notice that
what happened,
Lauren?
He got really warm,
not the first part of the stretching,
but at the very end of the
stretching is everybody onto that.
Okay,
good. So that's what he noticed,
right? And you can read all of it.
He said here if you want to. Okay.
Then he tries another experiment here.
He says,
if one end of a slip of cu
chook be fastened to a rod
of metal or wood and await
be fixed to the other extremity in
order to keep it in a vertical position,
then what will the Thong do?
So let's try that one.
So here's a piece of coot Chook and
we'll get it so you could see it here.
Uh,
let's see.
Yeah, you can see it a little
bit, but what needed some light?
Just a few.
And we'll put this on here.
So we're going to stretch it.
That's what he says to do.
No, I had more. What? I tried
this. I had more light before.
Let's see if I can do better
now I'll turn on this, uh,
this light. There we go.
Except that the thing is blocking it.
You get it into focus.
Okay. So I have, you know,
lines on paper there and you
can see how much it stretched.
Okay.
Forget it just a little bit.
Now what he's going to do is heat it.
Yeah.
So what does what you do when you heat it?
So what's going to happen to
the way we see the weight?
It just bolt just halfway
down below one of those lines.
Okay. What's going to happen when I
hit it? I'll hit it with this thing.
Which way will it move?
It'll expand, right?
So let's give it a try.
Is it going down?
Did it do anything?
It may be that it's,
I think my slide it out a little bit
here so that it's not rubbing against the
rod there.
Okay.
So how do you think Derek
triples? Okay, let's,
what's going to happen if I cool it off,
it shouldn't go back.
Let's watch.
So it's expanding when it cools
and it's contracting slowly when it heat.
Yeah.
This is weird,
right?
It expands when it cools
and contracts when it heats.
So we're going to have to deal with that.
So heating a tightly stretched
piece of rubber makes it contract.
Okay, so if stretching rubber generates
heat. That's what we did here.
Let's think a second.
What's going to happen when it
contracts if we let it go back?
Yeah.
Okay. Well we have several
possibilities. Okay.
It could be that the heat comes from
friction of the molecules rubbing by one
another.
If that's,
so what would happen when we
let it can track Carl and he,
well, he is way right? On the other hand,
if he comes from some other cause,
contraction may do the
opposite and absorb heat.
So what we're going to do is
stretch our rubber band is,
or our rubber as far as we can and
go like this to get it back to room
temperature while holding it tightly,
tightly stretched.
Cause remember this phenomenon
happens only at the very end.
Then we're going to
put it against our lip.
All right,
and do that.
What do you find?
Which of these isn't one or two?
Did it get hot when it
contracted or you get cold?
Both. Oh, cold. Okay. Yeah,
that's pretty dramatic isn't it?
You know,
GFE claims to have been discovered this,
but in fact I discovered it.
My nephew was having a birthday and I
was blowing up balloons that I happen to
do that. I thought, wow, that's
really something. Then I found,
then I found out I had been
scooped by two centuries. Okay,
so how does this work? What the heck
is going on with these polymers now?
If you've been to the Yale health center,
so what do you see?
If you go upstair up in the Yale health
center and look out toward the campus,
this is what you see.
A rather questionable view
from the Yale Health Center.
But right here is something
that's very interesting
and if you get up and look at it,
that's the two of them have Charles
Goodyear because he was a native of new
haven,
even though he discovered vulcanization
and in a Wolburn mass and died in New
York, a pauper, incidentally popper,
because he got involved with lawyers,
people tried to, uh, everybody, his
brother tried to break his patent.
So he hired Daniel Webster who
was secretary of State and,
and put on the most expensive,
uh, defense that ever happened,
have a patent and still he
lost his shirt. Okay. But,
but so he didn't know how it worked,
but maybe he can find out
now because there he is.
And if you go to that,
that obelisk there and then
down just a little bit farther,
you get to this guy and that
guy could tell him probably,
and conceivably did talk to him because
this is j Willard Gibbs who died,
who got his bachelor's
degree at Yale in 1858.
So two years before Goodyear died.
So they could have met,
but I don't think they did.
Right.
Gibbs could have given him some idea
about what was going on with rubber,
but the person who really could have
done it, the person are over here,
right here are two gravestones that
have different designs. The one,
they're both people from
this chemistry department.
One is John Gamble Kirkwood who was a
physical chemist and a theorist about
polymers. Right. And his, uh,
his gravestone tells everything
he did. Uh, not everything,
but quite a few things.
The awards he got and so on.
Uh,
but next to his is the
tomb of Lazarus on soccer.
His friend and colleague and the,
his tomb says Nobel laureate,
right?
His wife died 15 years later and the stone
was re to put her name on it as well.
And also to put on a footnote.
Okay. So they could, they could,
perhaps they're commuting down there
with Goodyear now and telling him what's
going on with this.
It has to do with statistical mechanics.
You remember that's what Gibbs did
because statistics is what makes rubber
contract after you've stretched it.
If you have a chain all
stretched out like this,
there's only one way to arrange
it between the two ends, right?
But if you,
if you contract it like that,
you can have it that way or that way or
that way or that way or that way. Right?
There are a zillion ways to have it
if it's contracted. So statistics,
entropy says it wants to have a
shorter distance between the ends.
So even though it might be
most stable in terms of heat,
that is the best con formation
when it's stretched out,
entropy will contract that again.
So if you have a whole bunch of these
polymer chains and you start to stretch
them out,
they're all tangled around and as you
stretch they get more and more parallel to
one another.
And finally they'll get so near,
some of them will get near one another
enough to crystallize just locally.
I mean these aren't like diamonds,
right?
But little local units of the thing are
together and when they come together
like that, they got their lower
and energy so they give off heat.
So when you stretch it at first,
that doesn't make any difference.
But the very last bit of the stretching
causes this crystallization and he comes
out, right? So there's
local con crystallization,
which contributes rigidity,
right? And releases heat,
right? On the other hand, when
you let it, if you put heat in,
it will melt these crystals and
entropy will cause it to contract,
right? And that, uh, so,
so then it'll allow statistics to make
the material contract like this and
you'll go backwards.
So it's actually entropy that brings
rubber back to its original shape.
Okay.
So fixed irregular cross links between
adjacent chains prevents crystallization.
So it doesn't become brittle when it's
cold because it doesn't crystallize.
And
uh,
it also prevents it from being goofy when
it's hot. How does that happen? Well,
the gooeyness has to do with the, with
the flowing of the molecules. So how,
but if you have something that's all
tangled up like this, how can it possibly,
how can you move a molecule, right? If
it's got to be really complicated shape,
the way it happens is very interesting.
It's a process called reputation.
Like a reptile.
This was an idea of a French physicist
who got the Nobel prize for this kind of
thing.
Okay.
So suppose you try to move
the chain length wise, right?
What will happen is like a carpet,
when you try to move a carpet,
you make a little wiggle in
it, right? A little hump,
and then you can move the Hump
along without moving anything else.
And it would go on and on all along the
chain and finally get to the other end
where it would be like that. And
finally the other end could move, right?
So it sort of crawls or goes like a
snake through all this tangle of other
polymers.
Right?
Now what does vulcanization
have to do with that? Right?
If you have crosslinks between the chains,
then they can't slide by one another.
So you can't do reputation.
So this stuff doesn't flow
and become gooey when it's hot
and that's what vulcanization does.
So there's no flow when hot and
it inhibits crystallization,
so it's not brittle when it's cold.
There's also vulcanization that
happens in the, uh, as I look around,
I'm not sure that any of you have
practice this, but you've heard of it.
I'm sure.
Here's a Robin Kelly.
I got permission to use this by
talking to Robin Kelly's mother.
And she tells me that Robin Kelly is
now a student at Harvard law school.
This was from some years ago,
but Robin Kelley did Irish dancing and
she wanted her hair to look like this for
Irish dancing.
So she vulcanized that,
right?
So here hair has sulfide groups coming
out and they linked to other chains.
So it's crosslinked, it's
vulcanized to begin with. Okay.
That holds the chains next to
one another in shape, right?
So what she did first was reduced the
dye sulfide cross links by excess basic
self, uh, hydro, uh, thiol.
So these are the two files that
are commonly used for that.
And notice that the sh is much
more acidic than, than hydroxide.
So if you have basic RSH,
you have s rs minus, right?
Okay.
So that can be do an sn,
two reaction on sulfur
and break that bond.
And that one can attack another
Thile take its hydrogen,
right?
And then that,
that Theo laid an ion can
do another displacement.
So what's happened,
okay,
is that we've reduced,
yeah,
the, the dye sulfide links to
make it to r a s h groups, right?
And now you can do the same thing
again and again and again, right?
And now the chains are pliable
and can be moved past one another.
So now she puts the soft spikes in and
curls her hair up tight and changes its
shape,
right?
And now she's got to make new cross
links again to vulcanize it, right?
So she's got it like this.
Now she oxidizes the thiols back
the dice all with hydrogen peroxide.
Now look at the Bond
Association energies that, oh,
Aho Aho members are very, the,
the oil was a very weak bond,
but the SS bond is not so weak and
that sh bond is weak compared to,
Ooh. So it's much favorable to start
on the left and go to the right.
It's favored by 30 kilocalories per mole.
So if she puts in peroxide,
right with thiol,
she'll get out the new cross
links and alcohol, right?
So you get the new cross links holding
the chains together in the shape you want
them to be.
So now our hair is vulcanized
in that everything's fine.
She can go Irish dancing.
Okay.
Now another way to hold the chains
together with cross links is to have ionic
groups on them.
And these ions tend to get together
with counter ions in clusters.
So that serves as a cross link,
but it's not a permanent cross link.
The covalent bonds are,
right?
So it's possible if you warm it to break
those at have and make things flow.
So this is thermo plastic.
You heat the polymer and you can reshape
it and then you cool it and it's got
the new shape,
right?
So there's after warming and
they got malleable cross length.
This is a father,
uh,
Newland at Notre Dame university
who figured out how to polymerize,
not the thing that had methyl up here,
which was the biological ISO preed unit,
but the one that has chloro. So that
gave a new compound called neoprene,
which had different properties and
they're all of these different, uh, uh,
polymers that have been made and this
list of according to how much they cost,
they get very expensive for flouro
silicon. Uh, how heat resistant they are.
Uh,
that low temperature,
the maximum temperature you can use them,
but also how they,
how they last oxidation,
whether they're substitutes, uh,
subject to weathering by ozone,
how strong they are.
So natural rubber is nice and strong at a,
it resists abrasion and tear.
It's very resilient. This is after, uh,
after crosslinking it after vulcanization,
but it's only fair on oxidation or Ozon.
You've probably seen rubber that's been
around a while are old telephone lines,
the rubbers falling off because
ozone has gotten to it, right?
So there are others that have,
that have a variety of properties.
I also wasn't important. One that's not
listed here is how they interact with uh,
oil or something like that.
Natural rubber is very bad with oil,
but some of these others, uh, like
neoprene is much better. So the,
you know,
designing a,
a tire for your car is a very complex
thing to mix different polymers to get
exactly the properties in different
parts of the tire that are necessary.
Now there are other ways
of doing polymerization as
well. For example, styrene,
you could imagine these double bonds
going together with a radical doing
addition to the double bond and
notice that as I drew at there,
it's random whether which ended,
the styrene got attacked,
but it would also be possible to imagine
that it always goes head to tail.
Always the same way. Why would that
be advantageous always to go this way?
Yeah,
because in fact, that's what it
does. It goes just head to tail.
Why?
Why don't you do additions like this
where you add to the center and leave that
radical?
Okay.
Why do you want to leave
this radical instead?
Amy?
It's secondary,
but much more important.
Yes,
it's been Zelig. It's like al the
lake. It has the double bonds to,
to interact with the SOMO.
Right? So both for both reasons,
it does that even if
it were a methyl group,
it would tend to do this because it
would be secondary the way Amy said.
But with fennel,
that's ever so much more so.
So that's 13 kilocalories more
stable than adding the other way.
Okay? Now there's also the question of
tactility, which we talked on before.
So, uh, you can have ISO tag, even
though these are all head to tail.
Notice that the, the methyl group is on
every other carbon. But you can have ice,
a tactic, Cindy, a tactic where I stacked
the, they're all the same. A tactic.
They alternate and a tactic is random.
And that's what you get.
You get right.
The regio chemistry is always head
to tail with the free radical.
But the stereo chemistry is random.
So it's a tactic.
But you can get ISO tactic
polypropylene from Ziegler,
not a catalyst that we talked about.
Uh,
two last lecture or the lecture before.
And Cindy tactic.
Remember I've used this fancy Kaminsky
catalysts that comes from one side than
the other than one side than the other.
And it has a mirror plane.
So you change the configuration each time.
Okay.
But there's another question
of selectivity when you
have two different monomers
in there. So for example,
methyl methacrylate and styrene.
So you could have block coat polymers
where you have a bunch of one coming
together and then a bunch of the
other one in a single chain. Right?
But another possibility is to have them
strictly alternate a, B, a, B, a, B.
Right?
And you can do that.
And the reason you can do it is because
of the rates of adding different
radicals to the alkenes.
So if you have that particular radical
at the end of the chain, right, the rea,
it adds to styrene faster than they
heads to methyl methacrylate that this,
this unit here was methylmethacrylate
that added to a radical there.
So now it's at the end of the chain and
it would prefer by a factor of two to
one to react with its own kind there.
Pardon me?
To react with styrene rather than
with its own kind. Right? Now,
what would you expect if you have
styrene as the, as the last radical,
right?
Notice what's interesting here.
I was wondering what this one was here.
It's this.
Okay.
That's now notice it's a factor
of two in the other direction.
One radical. Each radical prefers
to react with the other monomer.
Isn't that interesting? That's why it
goes a B, a, B, a, B. Why should that be?
This isn't surprising
because the this rack,
this radical is resonance stabilized
as Amy was telling us. Okay,
so that's, that's the fastest of all
these reactions and it's a good radical.
So that's reasonable. But why does this
one prefer not to form the good radical,
but the form what appears to be the
less good radical. Okay, so here,
here's our radical starting and it can
add to this to give that and that that
turns out it would be something like that.
And this 20th kilocalories per mole
exothermic, that's great. Right?
But if we start with it,
but if we react with the other alkene,
right, then it gives this,
which is less stable, right?
This one doesn't have as much Al Lilly
or Benzoic stabilization that you have
down here. Okay. But it's faster.
So it's faster to go to
the higher energy product.
That's not the Hammond
postulate. Right? Why? What?
Why is it twice as fast to go
to the less stable product?
So the transition state
for one looks like that,
the transition state for the
other, it looks like that, right?
What's good about the bottom one?
Yeah,
there's the top one. There's the
bottom one. And notice in this one the,
the carbon eel is good at
stabilizing high homos.
So you can have a resonance structure
with a minus charge here and a plus charge
here.
You can't do that up here as well.
This isn't specifically good at
stabilizing and ions. All right.
So you can have these resonance
structures here that you can't have there.
Right?
So the ionic resonance
structure, you could say,
stabilizes the transition state,
or if you wanted to talk
about it in terms of orbitals,
you'd say that the c double bond
o gives an unusually low Lumo,
so that's good when
the SOMO is not so low.
Yeah,
and this special stability applies
only at the transition state.
Once you formed this bond, then you can't
have a resonance structure like that.
So the product is not stabilized
by that kind of thing.
But the transition state is, which is what
makes these things turn around and go,
a, B, a, B, a, B. Okay.
Now I was going to go onto acetylene,
but we'll do that next time.